in today's eye on money the deadline to
file your taxes is next week have you
heard the original mid-april deadline
was extended three months to July 15th
because of this pandemic nearly 140
million Americans have already filed
their tax returns this year go you but
IRS data shows more than 11 million
people are still waiting for their taxes
to be processed the average tax refund
so far this year is two thousand seven
hundred and fifty nine dollars CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger joins
us now to discuss and sort it all up
where's Jill help help help my account
just called yesterday and said we need
this form this form this form this form
up so here we are even though we have
the two extra three extra months people
are still not ready so what do we need
to know at this point well I think if
the pandemic has shown us anything
around tax time it is that filing and
paying electronically is preferred you
mentioned that number of millions of
people waiting for their refunds we also
know that the IRS has said that as of
May the middle of May 4 point 7 million
paper returns hadn't been touched yet so
before you start to get get you all your
documentation together fire up your
computer and you want to file
electronically now if you make less than
sixty nine thousand dollars your
adjusted gross income you're entitled to
free software through the IRS just
search IRS gov free file that's really
important and if you do owe money not
everybody does more people get refunds
than not but if you do owe money you can
also do that electronically we have
heard some stories about people getting
kind of freaked out they sent paper
checks in earlier in the spring and
they've gotten no acknowledgment from
the IRS no check being cashed yet my
cash my check was cashed so kudos to the
IRS for that so what do people still
need more time Jill
well you can't file for an extension
that will give you until October 5th
there's a form 4868 again the IRS
website is what you want to go for here
because no one is answering the phones
at the IRS right now or very few people
so you find for an extension but an
extension comes with a caveat even
though you have extra time to file
you've got to estimate what you think
you owe if you do owe anything and
you've got to send the money in advance
so October 15th but you still have to
pay what you think you might have I
thought it's interesting that you just
said more people get refunds than not
but what if you can't afford to pay what
you know you owe this is a real problem
obviously right now there are people who
made money last year maybe they owe
taxes but they were counting on full
employment through the first three or
four months of this year now they're
sideline so there are a number of mess
methods first of all if you cannot pay
even if you could scratch together a few
extra bucks you should pay what you
think you can then there are these
options one is to go online you can get
an extension to pay for a hundred and
twenty days that's an online application
if you need more than 120 days then
you'll need an installment agreement
there is a third method I don't like
this method you can pay on debit or
credit cards that is associated with
higher fees so you're much better off
getting one of those two agreements
through the IRS if you cannot find the
money on hand to pay right now now
millions of people got money from the
for that from the government during this
time well does that money is that money
taxed so here just let's think about
this we have two different forms of
payments from the government we have the
economic impact payment and that would
be money received now in 2020 so we're
talking about next year's filing
deadline this would be in April the
economic impact payment not taxable
don't worry about that however
unemployment benefits are taxable and if
you know that you're getting these
benefits you have to understand there
are two ways that that money is going to
be taxed all at once next
jeer or potentially you can go on to the
IRS website have ten percent of that
money withheld I highly recommend you do
that if you can afford to do so to avoid
a nasty surprise next year gale all
right Jill Schlesinger nobody likes a
nasty surprise thank you very much